[Music]
plastic is polluting our oceans and our
entire planet meet two guys who are
recycling waste to help others this
great big story is made possible by BASF
we create chemistry plastic waste makes
up 85% of the waste on the beaches
around the world we've found a solution
to use that plastic waste and turn it
into products this is the Gomi speaker
so it's the Bluetooth speaker made
completely from Marble plastic waste we
take plastic waste from the local area
we take it here we clean it we then get
it ready for the ovens we melt it down
we hand Marble it to get patterns that
we like and the colors that we like and
then we put in the malls to heat up and
we press the mods together and then once
this little ball we take it apart and
we've got the products wound around 200
less teabags and mow it down for each
speaker so far this year we've saved 300
kilos of plastic away from being
incinerated collecting plastic waste
currently currently recycled in the UK
150 billion kilos a year and made of
this material and 99% of their studies
and recycled around the world so we take
that and we use that material and trying
to prove that it can be valuable now
from using plastic bags to plastic
bottles you have plenty of plastic
bottles and plenty of plastic mists
abundantly available we are trying to
use those plastic ways to make something
helpful for others
so this is our prosthetic circuit made
from six plastic bottles this person
exactly see the main connection between
the the artificial limb and the human
body so if we take a plastic bottle and
grind them into powder and from the
power we make a young I'm gonna use the
yarn to knit tear free form exactly to
the patient resilient limb put it on
over the cast and then put it into the
oven then we can make a prosthetic
socket
traditional advanced composite fiber
socket in a can range between the three
to six thousand dollars but this one we
could be able to do it in twelve dollars
because the recycled materials
we have done the patient trials in India
there's a lot of people in developing
world we can't afford the high-end
processes we wanted to change that using
this prosthetic socket made from
recycled plastic bottles
[Music]